はいということで同源ですえっと最近だ
japanese men u ターが僕
の日本語を評価する動画を出したみたいな
ので今日はそれを見て自分の感想を言い
たいと思いますではいきます
ペガイズユーチャーソフィ speak
japanese フェス所
remedios あー海外の方も回復術
市近江ているカープさん who
do i プロデュースピンキーグループ
4 c 3 po asd スピーカー
japanese and forth
japanese ppap to
do a form to dotk
sports ボーダーヘイズ
japanese for some
japanese
parder
アーレ see
her to
do
voodoo ifo ソーパー5st
同源オフィス黄金比はずユニークスキーを
p to do in japanese
5 ed 4 ing いいスピーカー
ゼッドん sa d speak
japanese わああああファン
ハウスメーカーウィッ日本で最も役立つ
スキルを生んだと思いますか者さん点眼
ローズです
ベストだーへっ japanese
exception ウィーク
sab ハートファイン this
takes a d スキャンピースプロ
スワイプ m a 4 s 山同業 hec
英国で自分の意見を意見というか感想言い
たいと思いますでまぁ僕と上位とだったら
どっちが上かというとか安全にジョイだと
思いますっていうのは
まあユーザーも一番動画動画の一番最後に
言ったと思うんですけど
むしろへその上位には外国人ボーイ
アクセントがありますかーっていう質問
自体がバカバカしいというかあのそこら
へんの日本人より上位の方がずっと上だと
思うんですねその話かたとかまぁその
は実がすごいていうかまあ他に書くその彼
が日本語日本語でも英語でもその話して
いるところを聞くとこの人マジで頭いい
なっていうのがすぐわかるんですねなので
その同源の日本語と上位の日本語どっちが
うまいかっていう質問はもうアウトアウト
ですねにまではもう会うと比べ物になん
ないんですよ上位の方がねぇて日和う前
からネイティブに近いですねたまに言わ
れる
僕のか勝つわけがないんですだからここで
上位をちょっと一旦外してもらってそのま
うっ音同源とだったらっていう話を a
してみようと思いますまあマットと僕と
だったらどっちが上かというとまあ確かに
裕太さんが言ったように
その自分の意見を正
努力せずに努力せずにというか自然に自分
の言いたいことを伝えるとか
その雄弁さんとか発音の面に関してもあの
マットの方が上だと思うんですねもので
まぁその結構全体的に上位に完全に負けて
ますした分多くの日本人は
マットの方がまあネイティブに近いと
答えると思うんですねただしここでどうし
ても言いたいことがあってそれは何かと
いうとまあ買っているところは多分一つ
だけあって
でそれは何かというと
ジョーズさです
me